I have a voicemail number the numbers
2192 david p here's a very anti-semitic
collar that calls every once in a while
and has all sorts of ideas about jewish
conspiracies and stuff take a listen to
this yeah mr. David I called before and
this is a I think to a pledge drive none
to pledge drives with ago if you're
thinking of getting any money since
you're a Zionist why don't you ask the
Israeli Lobby yeah they'd be happy to
give you money to help free speech TV oh
I don't you just call them yeah I'm sure
they've called you many times come on
don't you just correspond with them and
you can get as much money as you can
yeah you know to help the apartheid
system and you know to help apartheid in
general right yes because of course all
Jews are connected and there's a
conspiracy to give us money you know
saying that I'm a Zionist isn't an
argument ask me my view on a specific
issue or policy and then we can actually
talk about it this guy's been calling in
for a long time have you heard this guy
before have not heard the second
apparently he's called in to pledge
drives ago yeah he he apparently has
been calling us for a while about this
stuff and I can confirm that it's always
the exact same topic on today's bonus
show Stephen Hawking will travel to
space on Richard Branson's ship I will
give the full details of how I tried to
prevent people from urinating on the
side of my building during this past
weekend st. Patrick's Day parade and a
waiter refused to serve for latina
customers until he saw proof of
residency all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show david pakman.com
slash membership sign up the coupon code
works it's I voted 17